dans cette chambre il y a le fromages la
viande froide et le lait
ça c'est tout s'en va à la poubelle au
complet les pertes sont considérables à
sa nourritine estime qu'il jettera
l'équivalent de 30 000 dollars à la
poubelle 1 2 3 4 5 6 ça ça coûte 1600
dollars
son épicerie est sans électricité depuis
près de 24 heures un épisode qui n'est
pas sans lui rappeler la crise du
verglas de 1998 il s'en souvient très
bien et cette fois-ci les pertes sont
encore plus importantes c'est dur c'est
pas facile mais je vous le dise très dur
après 24 ans sont pas les mains et de
Québec désolé il déplore le plus
d'information reçu jusqu'à maintenant
quand retrouvera-t-il le courant il n'en
a aucune idée je suis hyper sain je suis
un petit épicerie je suis pas un grand
épicerie je suis une petite personne qui
est cette quantité imagine les autres il
ne veut prendre aucun risque Assan
condamne la plupart de ces
réfrigérateurs d'ailleurs le mapach est
sans équivoque lorsque la panne de
courant s'étire au-delà de 6 heures un
ménage
il faut jeter le lait la crème le
fromage à pâte molle et le yogourt les
viandes volaille poisson et fruits de
mer doivent aussi être jetés les fruits
et légumes entiers peuvent être
conservés même chose pour les condiments
à l'exception de la mayonnaise les œufs
doivent être jetés quand vous n'êtes pas
certaine que vous voyez vos aliments il
me semble que ils sont un petit peu
bizarre la texture est étrange la
couleur légèrement changé on prend pas
de chance effectivement des trucs comme
le fromage le jeter des jambons qui
c'est littéralement chaud quand tu
touches un ménage forcé pour tous ceux
privés d'électricité depuis la tempête
Stéphanie Robillard avait fait des
provisions pour Pâques qui se retrouvent
à la poubelle c'est à peu près 300
dollars que j'ai acheté puis là je vais
essayer de voir ça va rester bon mais là
on est vraiment rendu à l'étape que ça
fait presque 48 heures je prendrai pas
le risque le matin rappelle qu'il n'y a
aucun risque à prendre avec des aliments
dont l'apparence est suspecte en cas de
doute vaut mieux les mettre à la
poubelle
ici qui me permettra au Canada Montréal